hallo herzlich willkommen sallys wels
neben mir sitzt der rasende reporter
borat du warst bereits schon unterwegs
genau er hat uns gezeigt wie man die
gusseisen töpfe und die bretter
herstellt und dieses mal ist der borat
wieder unterwegs mit dank einer mission
mit papa zusammen mit ihrem papa genau
und zwar sind die beiden nach denen les
gereist und sie zeigen uns dort wie man
das englische herstellung los er mein
geschirr die teller
die bleche was das besondere ist genau
wer die menschen dahinter sind genau ich
war leider nicht dabei aber murat stunde
papa ist seitdem starkes team genau und
einfach mal transparenz zeigen dass
herstellt wehrlos gemacht wird und damit
ihr hoffnung habt was machen da nicht
gerade genau und dann erkläre ich euch
später war es die vorteile von im mai
sind und was man eben auch so alles
damit zubereiten kann
also würde ich mal sagen film ab
[Musik]
voll schön dass du dein papa
so jetzt sind wir in der fabrik und das
war ein besonderes anliegen ist zu
zeigen und katzen den medienwirksamen
bei jedem sechsten blocks an den cut
geschafft
die leute arbeiten hier
da ist gar so ok also wie gesagt
wahnsinn was wir hier gemacht haben 28
jahren hatte santos interview fährt ja
als ich vor zwölf jahren beim papa
vorgestellt hat da könnte ich mir das
vorstellen hier steht auch ein bisschen
made in germany drin ist auch eine coole
geschichte die ganzen maschine hat die
kommen aus deutschland die farben die
kommen aus deutschland seien im mai
kommt aus deutschland die die türken die
liebe die deutsche handwerkskunst extrem
da gibt es zum einen spruch den kind
jeder typisch armani wir genau da gibt's
der spur heißt einfach arbeiten tür
gewählten fleißig sind aber beendet
wegen deutsch aber der deutsche ist
immer noch das perfektionistische ein
bisschen ins spiel bringen kind jeder
element und deswegen wird
qualitätsmedien germany sehr hoch
angesehen hatte seine sprüche wurde
immer maske ist ein türke 14 deutsche
doch einfach ihre anstellung oder 10
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wie so ein produkt von anfang bis zum
ende
wie das verarbeitet bearbeitet wird bis
er jetzt jetzt wird man den anfang und
zeigen wo das rohmaterial angeliefert
wird
[Musik]
hier wird das material angeliefert ist
der grundträger shop und das besondere
an einer qualitäten im mai merkel das
ist 08 und material in essen oftmals in
baumärkten oder so brauchen 06.05
material verkauft und 98 rohmaterial
stickstoff eigentlich und daran merkt
man auch nach hat die qualität die wir
nachher nutzen also es darf keine tasse
sein wind kommt mit die tasse weg
deswegen müssen wir nun achter material
das ist wirklich qualitativ hochwertig
ist richtig gut
er wird genau
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir einen grundstock und
hier sieht man für unsere für unsere
buchte formen macht er hier zum beispiel
der schritt
[Musik]
und mit dieser form gehen wir zweiter an
die presse und dann wird es nun die tief
gezogen und wie sie das machen das
zeigen jetzt
[Musik]
so soll das blech jetzt aus ihr seht der
rand ist noch ziemlich groß und jetzt
geht es weiter
und hier wird der anteil mit gnade
begradigt und zusammengeschnitten sagt
schon mal hinrichten politischer
ausgleich und her um das fertige blatt
das ist der grund stoff aus dem die
träume sind und aus dem main ist jetzt
gehen wir weiter an die nächste station
das ist jetzt der eltern aber es ist
eine spannende erfahrung
und zwar ganz was kummer herr j und zwar
folgendes des wehres viel zu scharf kann
die und auch so schafft hätte es ihm
auch nicht deswegen tun sie immer so
umbiegen und das ist nun der
scharfkantig ist
[Musik]
jetzt haben eine komplette grundform
schon fertig das ist jetzt wirklich
ideal ist es auch immer scharfkantig und
jetzt kümmert zum veredeln gehen und
dann schauen wir was aus diesem bleche
wird perfekt zusammen
[Musik]
so jetzt wollte ich schon weiter zeigen
aber jetzt gehen sie dann in die pause
es ist wirklich so um 9 uhr machen die
hier eine 15-minütige pause brauchte
pause ihr seht ist doch eine richtig
harte arbeit und was nachher für
einzelne schritte dabei ist ist echt der
wahnsinn
das geht von hand zu hand hier die
jüngste pause verdient jetzt haben wir
eigentlich form fertig und jetzt bei und
gemein ist sowas genial das ist eine
aktion natürlich ihr seht das hier ist
einfach so glaspartikel gebrochenes glas
und es ist erde und es ist wirklich er
das ist die chemische und es wird
zusammen mit mit wasser vermischt und
dann kommt unsere trommel rein und da
wird einfach zusammen richtig gut für
mich und das ihr merkt dass er dich hab
ich gerade gefressen habe ich noch nie
gegessen hast du nie gemacht doch aber
siehst du das ist nichts anderes und
wird dafür sieht man das natürlich ist
es immer aber hat folgendes gemacht der
hat noch blaupigmente rein gemacht und
jetzt wurde die farbe heraus wahnsinn
es war es ein absolut natürlich und die
farben die kommen aus deutschland
ihr seht völlig natürlich
und zunächst mal probieren oder konnte
blöd das machen wir nicht
ich wollte es immer probieren könnte es
nicht hat nicht mal das mund gesteckt
das hat bei mir nie aufgehört jetzt was
ihr feuerwerk an mund genommen habt das
ist das gleiche nur in grau und jetzt
wird meine form die vor geholt habe ihr
einfach reingemacht wie sowas wenn die
grundierung und das ist dass er merkels
will ich das gleiche ist man hier zum
beispiel kann ich auch im mund nehmen
passiert auch nichts so nachdem ich die
ganze farbe hier gefressen haben im
ganzen unternehmen gebe ich jetzt dieses
bleche dass ein bisschen kleiner jetzt
haben jetzt keine andere gebunden und
ohne der macht es hier und zwar tut es
einfach nur eintauchen sondern über den
tag verteilt so viel spaß
ich habe mein leben ohne farbe gesetzt
und dann an diesem tag soll jetzt ein
bisschen antrocknen und von hier geht es
jetzt in den ofen und dann ist eine
untrennbare verbindung 242 eine
untrennbare verbindung ja das möglich wo
er jetzt inzwischen schon bei
scheidungen der zu teuer wie ausland
nehmen so und hier haben wir schon was
beschichtet ist
so wie so was kommt
so kann ich die ganzen tag den ofen
bestücken
wo ich muss schneller arbeiten waren sie
dann musst du echt power haben
und so geht es in den ofen rein
ich kann gar nicht reden und arbeiten
gleichzeitig ist und so geht es im ofen
rein und kommt fertige brand auf der
anderen seite schwarz schon raus in
wickrath der open air ausstellung über
850 grad hat diese offen
und der bekommt er im november anfang
dezember 9 ofen hilfe größeren weil
inzwischen produziert er nur fast
ausschließlich noch für uns also über 14
zwischen 40 und 60 seine auslastung
machen wir schon aus wahnsinn oder jetzt
nicht mehr deutsche maschine oder
schwäbische schwäbische kuka roboter
das unternehmen hat eine party ich habe
mich noch nicht also wenn irgendwo in
deutschland zweige wahl auftaucht dann
war ich übrigens nicht kannte
das ist es wert ist zum türkischen mokka
aufzubrechen
ja ich weiß ja dass als ausgesprochen
meint nord zurück dass du kannst ja
indirekt mein gott wie ist es nun mal
daher okay
wahnsinn das ist super macht echt
wahnsinn
ihr seht da muss man richtig eine coole
handfertigkeit haben das ist ein cooles
eingespieltes team
er hängt immer die haken hing er hängt
das ding auf und der holzhaus
unternehmen dies mit handschuhen
natürlich und lebens hier drauf allein
da würde ich schon scheitern das ding so
zu stapeln dass es nicht um krieg erst
einmal voll durch die ganze arbeit
gemacht man kommt irgendwo einen
vollpfosten wie ich aus deutschland haut
ist und warum
wahnsinn jetzt haben wir die grundierung
drauf und diese diese päckchen hier die
bleiben natürlich nicht schwarz und
jetzt kommt noch die veredelung mit
verschiedenen farben das heißt unter den
weißen gelb und wie es gemacht wird das
zeige ich euch jetzt so das ist jetzt
unsere form wie es aus dem backofen
gekommen und das geht nicht jetzt muss
der marke und zwar mutig aber ist hier
der lack ihr kind sozusagen und jetzt
bringen ein bisschen farbe ins spiel
und zwar wollen die meisten ja innen
drin eine weiße beschichtung haben das
ist auch die gleiche farbe in den mund
nehmen
trotzdem haben sie am mundschutz und
damit einer bitte jetzt mal richtig
schön lackiert und das mache alles per
hand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so ist auch die farbe und diese immer
schmeckt immer noch gleich nur das ist
ein bisschen grobkörniger ist mein gott
diese szene habe immer schon zweimal
gedreht ich habe schon mindestens zwei
liter einmal gegessen heute
er trat gesehen hoch teilnehmer wer hat
ihn drin alles lackiert ich rede man von
lackieren markieren herzlich mit nach
ihm ihren ist es aber nicht
er hat alles abgespritzt sozusagen und
jetzt kommt es jetzt wird es aufgehängt
und dann kommt den ofen bei über 850
grad allein nur damit unseren weiß
aussieht
[Musik]
freilich habe und ich wir nehmen jetzt
die formen von hier und das nennt sich
rat und vielleicht auch den grill
sozusagen und jetzt war alles schön rein
muss da vorsichtig sein weshalb keine
schläge gegeben
der lacht sich halb verstehe ich bin zu
langsam joggen aber schon klar ich
glaube wir hier drinnen arbeiten wäre
wenn sie kein geld verdienen mein gott
effekt zum flötet nicht aufzuhängen
ich probiere es aber trotzdem ich gebe
nicht auf
da muss ich mit den händen aufpassen man
darf nicht an den rand hin kommen weil
sonst man das sofort dunkel und dann
müssen sie mal drüber lackieren was so
einfach aussieht ich gar nicht so
einfach wenn man sich mal vorstellen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ihr seht jetzt geht das tor zur hölle
auf die waren damit hier bei dir zum
arbeiten
das ist und nach sieben minuten kommen
die backformen gebrannt raus 850 grad
richtig schön drauf halten ist richtig
heiß wenn du diese bleche daheim haben
egal was für meile daheim habt schaut
mal hier in diese kordel rein da habt
ihr immer da sind sowieso viele löcher
das hat jedes immer gut hat es und zwar
sind es gerade diese dinger hier siehst
du wo das team aufgehangen
[Musik]
ok jetzt ist aus dem ofen rausgekommen
und es ist noch richtig heiß war warm
ist und diese innen drin ist jetzt
komplett weiß und außen dieses anthrazit
aber dann wird es noch nicht fertig weil
wir möchten es ja vielleicht außen grün
oder gelb oder petrol in verschiedenen
farben
wenn wir das machen dann gehen wir jetzt
nach hinten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das hat mir mut helmer jetzt angemalt
lackiert und will mit der farbe
infizierten lenken aber ich mache dieses
mal nicht und wie gesagt jetzt kommt es
doch mal hin offen das muss ich nicht
nochmal zeigen und dann und wann dann
dank kommt es nicht so raus perfekt
rästv dunkler und dann kommt es wirklich
so raus und dann ist schon kennen
so beziehen anthrazit blech das petrol
ist noch immer offen aber hier kann ich
zeigen
jetzt kommen eine letzte schritt der
veredelung und zwar kommt noch dieser
sally backen braucht jetzt habe ich das
drauf gemacht und jetzt kommt wirklich
nur wegen diesem logo geht es jetzt
nochmal in ofen wird noch mal gebrannt
und am ende am ende drin war kommt raus
und sieht dann so aus und es stand mich
wichtig ist nicht unser produkt wir
haben hier für die formen bezahlt und
wie gesagt es ist unser brennt und das
produkt ist jetzt eigentlich fertig
[Musik]
aber ihr seht es wird vier mal gebrannt
diesmal ist die hand genommen hat das
ist eine richtige hand aber in der
richtige manufaktur gastronomie gemacht
mit seiner familie
und da gibt es ja noch was ganz ganz
besonderes ist wieder eine ganz
eigenwillige handarbeit drin steckt man
kann auch verschiedene designs machen
das machen aber erst nächstes jahr und
design sowie wir zeigen dass wirklich
abschnitt alles handgemacht und alles
unikate
hier sind wir alle der macht hier
wirklich unikate
das heißt also jeden becker mit hans mit
dem spritzen mit verschiedenen farben
[Musik]
so jetzt macht es gerade einen haken
drauf und hängt es dann hier wieder auf
diesem grill auf und dann geht es dann
in den ofen damit noch mal gebrannt
[Musik]
und so sieht der becher außerdem fertig
ist eigentlich richtig cool oder so ist
er noch vor dem brennen und so nach dem
brennen um ein ja das richtig cool
gemacht sieht man den stecke ich mir ein
nach deutschland
[Musik]
so jetzt zeigen was richtig genial ist
deshalb jetzt will ich gefalle nicht
mehr der typ der so unifarben macht aber
der halle macht was richtig genial ist
nicht im handel jetzt mal gerade dieses
blech es gibt es bei uns auch das ist
dieses pizza black hat allah will jetzt
passt mal auf was der macht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt sind wir gerade luft und tools ein
bisschen verstreuen
so jetzt warten wir ab wie das aussieht
wenn es im ofen drin war das kommen sie
nicht raus kann ich schon zeigen los wie
es aussieht unser wissen offenbar kommt
mit nicht so raus bist richtig genial
aus und ja das mit grün gemacht sieht
auch cool aus und hier daran im anderen
grün also ich will es einfach genial und
jedes einzelnen minister halle hier
macht ihr seht hier
wow wie soll ich kraterlandschaft und
wie gesagt nach dem rennen kommt so raus
wie auch nicht geniale art etwas zu
veredeln
da sind wirklich denn der der
kreativität keine grenzen gesetzt und
ihr seht alles ist ein unikat saumäßig
viel handarbeit und absolut es ist
absolut werd wahnsinnig
hier werden und auch unsere teekannen
gemacht als er wasser pop ist tolle
daran ist natürlich dass die
induktionstechnik so einfach metallisch
und innen drin trotzdem eine glas
beschichtung hat das wasser schmeckt
nicht metallische dabei natürlich helfe
von der angeschweißt
hier wird jede teekanne die wir
herstellen lassen unsere mrt kann heran
zusammengesetzt und zusammengeschweißt
gerade diese hälse hier werden alle per
hand geschweißt und zusammengefügt und
es ist wirklich genial ist es absolut
handarbeit
[Musik]
was sich auch ganz cool finde das ist
natürlich gang und gäbe dass die
mitarbeiter immer essen egal wie groß
die firma ist der inhaber bezahlt immer
dieses mittagessen ist übrigens bei uns
in der 5 salis welt auch so auf jeden
fall der union macht wie ich so alles 41
45 mitarbeiter wasser hat
ich bin jeden tag essen geliefert das
heißt zur mittagszeit wieder alles
zusammen der kantine essen und essen
zusammen was ich natürlich nicht gang
und gäbe was die jetzt ja auch gerade
machen wir probieren auch neue dinge aus
neue farben zb eine neue farbe was auch
erst anfang nächsten jahres kommen wird
dieses pink sein
dieses land große diesen lang rosé tun
und vor allem dieses grün und da geht es
dann so eine helle richtung wir
probieren jetzt auch grad - samt haaren
aus welche farben sind die kommenden
trends in welche richtung es gehen und
ich bin sehr sehr natürlich oder hier
natürlich das petrol as kennt ja schon
und ich finde dieses mal richtig genial
den smart ist aber momentan nicht die
farbe ist es um gebrannte es ist
gebrannt
das ausprobieren neuer farbe aus neue
formen und ich mal gespannt was in
nächster ab und zu kommt was technisch
auch kommen wird sind rechteckige formen
als rechtliche backformen aus immer es
wird unser nächstes ziel sein
[Musik]
so jetzt immer fällig ich habe jetzt
alles immer angeschaut haben wohl auch
noch paar farben abgesprochen
ein paar neue designs die dann erst
nächstes jahr kommen werden
aber mir war es einfach wichtig dass wir
mal sehen was hergestellt wird
viele unternehmen machen das licht
zeigen auch nicht diese transparenz wir
haben hier nichts zu verbergen
dessen menschen die wir kennen und auch
gern die auch lieb schätzen inzwischen
und freunde habt ihr papa hat auch ein
paar tränen verdrückt wenn er sieht was
seine tochter hier macht unter ich
glaube ich habe aufgehört zu weinen wenn
man das sieht man einfach der vita der
hat ja die ganze zeit da war genial
einfach stolz drauf und deswegen habe
ich auch mitgenommen und allah war so
sicher gelandet
vielen dank habe ich gerade gesagt dass
uns gezeigt hat
okay ganz ganz liebe grüße nach
deutschland
und wir gehen jetzt und zu zeigen was
mit dem alles machen kann
ok also bis gleich
[Musik]
viele von euch haben es jetzt schon aber
dass diese mini vor die gar nicht mehr
ja genau ja da ist es unser im mai
geschirr und er ist jetzt nichts was wir
erfunden haben das gibt es schon das
gibt es ja schon seit jahrhunderten das
hat die oma schon immer benutzt weil es
wirklich auch ein sehr einfach so
natürliches material ist moore hatte
erklärt das ist einfach nur metall mit
glas und der vorteil ist einfach dass
wir uns wirklich auf jedem herd benutzen
kann zu omas zeiten gab es noch ein
induktionsherd aber das geschäft
induktions geeignet ihr könnt auf jedem
herd benutzen auch im backofen und
zucker auf dem grill und vor allem ist
es sehr hygienisch denn man hat ihr
wirklich eine glatte glas beschichtung
und die ist geschmacksneutral aroma
neutral
das heißt ich kann darin heute in
herzhaften auflauf machen mit ganz viel
knoblauch und trotzdem das ding
auswaschen und dann später einfach nur
zum trinken oder was süßes buchteln und
der geschmack überträgt sich einfach
nicht ganz einfach zu reinigen
ihr könnt auch wirklich eigentlich in
der geschirrspülmaschine reinigen aber
das sage ich immer dazu
ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich vom glas
dass das glas mahlzeit matt wird liegt
einfach daran dass der
geschirrspülmaschine viel salz und
dieses geschirrspülmittel verwendet und
natürlich auch klarspüler und das greift
einfach glas an und eben dann wird es
ein bisschen macht also entweder im glas
programm waschen und wirklich sehr
schonend
ich empfehle aber trotzdem immer einfach
kurzerhand reinigen ich will einfach
dass es schon glänzend bleibt und nicht
meter zeit macht wird genau es gibt
sachen die tut nämlich viele maschinen
wie jetzt hat zum beispiel auch
gusseisen templeton dielingen mir am
herzen und deswegen stelle ich sie da
einfach nicht ein was ich auch ganz gut
findet ist es wirklich kratzfest ihr
könnt darin wenn er hier was herzhaftes
gebacken habt wirklich mit einem messer
drin schneiden oder pizza oder mit pizza
rat ich würde allerdings dem messer
zuliebe nicht tun denn mit messer auf
glas schneiden macht natürlich das
messer stumpf aber nicht die form kaputt
und wie gesagt könnt ihr auch eine pizza
haben
und einfach wenn ihr darin die pizza
gebacken hat mit dem hinterrad direkt
die spitzen schneiden könnte auch machen
und das auch ganz praktisch ist und dass
ich auch echten vorteil von diesen
natürlichen material
ihr könnt mit dem schneebesen
unterrühren ohne das was abgekratzt wird
wie bei teflon zum beispiel oder auch
bei allen stunden die sie wählen sie
kunststoff und ihr könnt ihr wirklich
drin rühren das kratzt keine glas
beschichtung ab es kann natürlich
irgendwann sein dass ihr optische
kratzer bekommen weil einfach dann das
metall hier spuren hinterlässt aber ich
sag immer dort so ganz ehrlich das sind
gebrauchsgegenstände
ich will dass es außen schönen glänzend
bleibt deswegen spiele ich per hand aber
innen ich meine da ist immer was zu
essen und an sonst noch immer nicht
fallen lassen und nicht gelesen oder
stoßen ist ein neues bietet klar ist
aber wenn mal was passiert jetzt
wirklich da so einen kleinen stoß
gemacht und es blättert was ab dann ist
es nicht schlimm ihr könnt einfach
weiter benutzen und vor allen dingen ist
auch alles handgemacht sondern unikat
also jedes einzelne teil was ihr habt
egal ob in form ob taste ob schälchen
oder große schale ist wirklich per hand
gefertigt und per hand auch farbig
gemacht genau ich finde es halt immer
war immer noch fasziniert dem video habe
ich das ja gesehen wie erst das ganze
weiß gemacht hat und dann macht er die
gelbe farbe drauf wenn wir daran bleibt
trotzdem weist so bevor man sie
vergessen wissen die aktuellen farben
dieses momentan gibt und es gibt sogar
inzwischen alles mit punkten das hat mir
gewünscht dass auch voll viele wollten
diese punkte haben ist sowieso ein
klassisches retro design und die monte
machen wir einfach immer auf diese
tiefen blech genau bei den gibt sehr
sehr viele farben das sind nur zwei
beispiele wo was ist ganz ganz neu
kontern was soll ich versprochen haben
sie diese pastelltöne aber wirklich erst
zu ostern dh man auch im monat darauf
aber ansonsten ist alles da und die
gibt's dann auch mit punkte und ohne
punkte und das sind glaube ich auch
viele farben die euch gefallen
berger fand sie sehr gut und was mir
auch überlegt haben war allgemein das
versuchen wir immer zu machen
bei der verpackung zum beispiel auf auf
recycling material zu achten dass nicht
zu viel verpackung kein kunststoff kein
plastik ganz ganz wichtig und so sieht
es natürlich aus so hängen sie nachher
auch überall
deswegen mussten wir auch hier im innern
weil sie weg ist auch zum beispiel in
österreich beim interspar hängt muss es
natürlich fest bleiben denn wenn es
darunter fällt geht halt wirklich kaputt
wenn es aus zwei meter höhe runterfällt
und deswegen haben wir da natürlich
etiketten dran das kann man hier kurz
zeigen also ist auch eine meisten fragen
unserer hiesigen klebestreifen der ist
ich muss sagen das war nicht toll
gewählt weil philipp machen jetzt dieses
wir diese verpackung weg dann hängt noch
diese etikett dran und da müssen
hingehen einem fön oder krieges einfach
abziehen also dann müsst ihr wirklich
nicht lange rummachen im wasser oder so
sondern geht einfach hin
sobald nämlich das blech warm wird könnt
ihr das etikett ganz einfach lösen ich
kann das ja mal kurz zeigen
[Applaus]
wie wichtig war es jetzt mir persönlich
in dieser serie was ja auch schon im
display das gusseisen wir schon gesehen
dass in den völlige transparenz habt
dass ihr wisst wer es herstellt wo es
hergestellt wird und auch die ganze
arbeit dahinter sieht oftmals ist so
manches dinge nicht wert wenn man es ist
einfach nur liegt und warum man weiß gar
nicht wie es produziert wurde
jetzt hat einmal gesehen wie viele
schritte der szene die oft ist lackiert
wird wie oft das gebrannt wird wie
menschen wieder menschen müssen ja in
der in der hand haben und das war mir
das wichtige dass ich irgendwann seht
was passiert hinter den kulissen und der
mix kommt wieder ein neues video
seit darauf gespannt und ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen wäre toll wenn im park
kommentare waren genau und wenn ihr noch
weitere infos wollten sie mit michael
schär an schaut einfach auf meine
technik kanal vorbei
da habe ich ein eigenständiges video
dazu gemacht ich erkläre euch das
geschirr ich zeige euch ein paar
beispiele was man machen kann wie man es
pflegt und reinigt und ja dort könnt ihr
auch gerne vorbeischauen wenn euch das
video gefallen hat dann schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
und ich muss echt sagen murat ich bin
sehr stolz auf dich denn du bist
wirklich wieso murata fliegende reporter
markus sport immer ganz ganz liebe grüße
aus sehen sie übrigens vom und erst
selber sehr sehr stolz auf die sendung
mit der maus sehen jetzt dass dieser nur
mit der ort
[Musik]